For a given 1.5 mile section of road,
two 12 foot wide lanes are being studied
to review their pollutant contribution
to a local water source. Local
regulations limit pollutant
concentrations and runoff to 2 mg per
liter for inorganic contaminants and 3
mg per liter for organic contaminants.
Due to local traffic patterns, the
pollutants in the following table are
accumulating on the road at the provided
rates. From the information given, would
either the inorganic or organic
compounds cause a violation of local
water quality standards during a 1-in
storm? Assume the entire rainfall
becomes runoff and that no other sources
contribute to the receiving water body.
[Music]
So this problem has a long problem
statement, but it's essentially asking
us to find the concentrations of the
inorganic contaminants and organic
contaminants respectively and then
compare them to the provided limits.
Let's do this in the following
steps. First, let's note that
Hg, mercury, and PB lead are our
inorganic contaminants.
Nitrogen
N and phosphorus P are our organic
contaminants. Both the civil and
environmental reference manuals have
periodic tables in them if you need to
look these up. And both manuals also
mention that mercury is Hg in the
conversion factor
section. So let's get into our
steps. Step one is going to be find the
inorganic washoff pollutant
mass. So first we will sum up our
inorganic contaminants.
Mercury is going to be
0.032 and lead is going to be
0.18. These are in units of
kilograms per
mile
day. Multiplying by the number of days
since our last rain event since that
will be the amount of time that the
pollutants have been
accumulating. And then multiplying again
by the length of the
roadway, which is 1.5 miles.
And then finally, we could go one step
further right now and also figure out
what the wash off percentage is. So
that's going to be 90 over
[Music]
100. And this will calculate out to
859 kg.
Step two, we can perform the same steps
for the organic washoff pollutant
mass. So just up here if it wasn't
clear, miles cancels, days cancel,
leaving us just with
kilogram. So for the organic compounds,
we will do the same thing. Nitrogen
0.25,
phosphorus
0.19 kilogram per
mile
day time 3
days time
1.5
miles
time 0.9 same as the number up here for
the wash off. And that's going to give
us
1.782 kilograms of pollutant
mass. Step three, we want to calculate
the volume of runoff from the road
during a 1-in storm.
So, we have a 1-in
storm, and let's convert this to leaders
since that's what we need to
compare our final results in later.
[Music]
So we have 1 in
* 1 ft over 12
in times 1.5 miles of
road times
5,280
ft in a
mile times two lanes given In the
problem
statement, each lane being 12 ft
wide times
7.48
gallons per cubic foot. Since right now
we have foot, foot foot, and
foot. And then
finally times
3.79 L per
gallon. And if we do all of this math
out we will see that we are left with
just liters. Inches
cancel. Feet 1 2 and three will cancel
with cubic
feet. This should be 12 feet per lane.
So lane and lane cancel.
miles
cancel and
everything then gallons cancel. So all
we have left are liters here and that's
going to be about
L. So step
four is going to be finding the
inorganic concentration using the
pollutant mass and the volume of runoff.
So
kg over
L and then 10 6
mg in 1 kilogram to complete our unit
conversion. And this will give us about
1.91 milligrams per
liter. We can see that this is below the
limit specified in the problem statement
for inorganic
contaminants. For step five, we're going
to find the organic
concentration. So that's going to be
1.782
kg over
449 051
L 10
6 mg over 1
kilogram. And this is going to come out
to
3.97 mg per liter.
We can see that this is above the legal
limit specified in the problem statement
for organic
[Music]
contaminants. So the question is asking
would either the inorganic or organic
compounds cause a violation during a
storm and our answer is that the organic
compounds would cause a violation which
is our second answer here.
So this problem has no real tricks to
it. You just have to perform some basic
math and unit conversions as well as
recognize which pollutants are organic
and which are
inorganic. And that's all it takes to
solve this problem.